[Aplausos]
muchos de ustedes han sido parte de un
ritual caníbal
un ritual sangriento y tan iba
y ese es un plato de pozole
qué rico no
y es que el pozole no siempre fue así
trasladémonos a la época prehispánica
en lo alto de una pirámide un sacerdote
realizado un sacrificio para honrar a
los dioses entonces aventaba a ese
hombre rodando por la pirámide donde ya
lo esperaban cocineros con grandes ollas
con un caldo de maíz hirviendo este
hombre era descansado y sus pedazos eran
aventados a la olla
y entonces este platillo era consumido
solamente por las personas más
especiales
historias como esta hay muchas esta por
ejemplo dicen que es una que está en la
historia general de las cosas de la
nueva españa y es que el pozole antes se
comía con carne humana
yo me imagino que llegó un español y
dijo yo tengo por aquí un poquito que no
sé si le quieres aventar mejor
y por eso hoy comemos el pozole así y
porque les cuento esto porque yo estoy
seguro que la próxima vez que ustedes
tengan enfrente un plato de pozole se
van a acordar de esto
y es muy probable que la persona que
tengan al lado de ustedes le platiqué en
esta misma historia
y es que nosotros vivimos de contar
historias
hacen lo mucho
estaba yo frente a un reclutador
y yo viendo al techo
a una luz blanca a un zumbido eterno
y el reclutador retomado mi atención y
me decía y por qué te tengo que
contratar a ti para una posición de
ventas
si no tienes experiencia en ventas
lo bien le dije
no no deberías de contratarme a mí
tienes razón
pero sabes
quisiera contarte una historia
y es que contar historias es la manera
en que nuestro cerebro conoce al mundo
démonos cuenta nos la pasamos contando
historias es incluso tan impresionante
el poder de contar una historia
que si nosotros tenemos ese mismo plato
de pozole lo imaginamos frente a
nosotros
exprimimos 3 limoncitos o 4 agarramos
una cucharada
lo vemos y lo introducimos a nuestra
boca para sentir el ácido de limón
estoy seguro que muchos de ustedes en
este momento lo sintieron
ese es el poder de contar una historia
al contar una historia hacemos que
nuestro cerebro reaccione a algo que no
está a sensaciones que no existen
imaginemos hace muchos años
a un antílope en una pradera a este
antílope le vamos a llamar juan
juan el antílope tiene un amigo que se
va a llamar
y juan y pedro acaban de llegar a la
pradera con su familia
hay una pradera muy bonita hay un río
cercano juan y pedro entonces deciden
seguir el río y llegar a un maravilloso
lago
en ese lago pedro se acerca a tomar agua
y de repente la tragedia
eric el cocodrilo brinca y se come a
pedro juan regresa corriendo con su
familia y solamente se les queda viendo
así
le pusieron cara humana juana pedroia
eric no no la tienen son un antílope y
un cocodrilo
pero si esto mismo hubiera sucedido con
un juan el ser humano y un pedro ser
humano
juan si hubiera podido regresar con su
familia y contarles que allí en el agua
hay un cocodrilo quizá organizarse con
los demás aldeanos regresar al lago
cazar al cocodrilo y regresar a pintar
esta misma historia en piedra le suena
sí desde que inició la humanidad hemos
contado historias de hecho es tanto lo
que hacemos contando historias que está
comprobado que el 65 por ciento de todo
lo que hacemos y decimos cuando estamos
interactuando con una persona es a
través de historias imagínense cuánto
tiempo es eso si viviéramos 100 años por
regla sesenta y cinco años de nuestra
vida las pasaríamos contando historias
es muchísimo tiempo
luego hay que me dice bueno pero cuando
dormimos no contamos historias sí claro
que sí nos la contamos a nosotros mismos
en las tramas más extrañas que existen
en esta vida pero soñamos en historias y
de hecho despertamos y decimos ahí qué
crees fíjate que soñé
y contamos una historia el reclutador me
seguía viendo
y yo le dije mira
cuando yo tenía cinco o seis años estaba
yo sentado un día en un teatro
presenciando una masacre
un cazador que mataba y maltrataba a un
animal
y ese animal a su vez había maltratado a
una persona adulta y se la había comido
estaba viendo caperucita roja
y le dije y fue para mí tan
impresionante el poder de esos actores
contando esta historia
que yo dije que yo quería hacer eso no
matar al animal ni contar historias
después pasó el tiempo y yo crecí
y llegó el momento en el que tenía que
decidir que iba a ser para estudiarlo
y dije bueno pues si me gustan las
historias pues quiero seguir contando
historias y entonces decidí a estudiar
comunicación porque allí había medios
para contar historias estaban los
periódicos la radio la televisión el
cine eran infinitas las posibilidades
hoy en día las redes sociales
todas las maneras que teníamos de contar
historias
hace la carrera
me metí a grupos de teatro de actuación
seguía contando historias y
y me di cuenta de algo le dije al
reclutador
en seguir apuntando
y salen esta es una de las industrias
más exitosas sólo el año pasado el cine
que es la industria que cuenta historias
generó 36 billones de dólares de
ganancias y saben qué es lo peor de todo
que son unos tramposos nos cuentan la
misma historia una y otra y otra y otra
vez y seguimos pagando porque nos la
cuenten
ustedes conocen los cuentos medievales
donde hay castillos hay princesas hay un
tirano malvado
existen las peleas con espadas cuantas
veces no nos han contado ese cuento
cuantas veces no lo hemos leído en
historietas en libros en cuentos para
dormir
saben qué pasa si es el mismo cuento que
nos han contado millones de veces lo
único que hacemos es trasladarlo a las
estrellas la franquicia más exitosa del
planeta star wars es un cuento medieval
hay caballeros peleando con espadas por
un tirano nada más que son láser
y es que el cine
la industria cinematográfica tiene
muchas maneras de contar estas historias
ya hay fórmulas existen las fórmulas
todas estas fórmulas y maneras en que el
cine hace para contarnos historias están
ahí al alcance de todos nosotros en un
libro en una librería solo que yo
siempre he dicho que están en el cajón
incorrecto
porque para encontrar estas fórmulas
para contar historias tienes que ir al
cajón que dice cine y yo digo que es el
cajón debería de pasar sea uno que
dijera cosas que necesito para vivir
porque contar historias es eso
porque nos la pasamos contando historias
el reclutador pegaba en su poder lo
le dije mira
después de todo esto yo me di cuenta de
algo
me di cuenta
que hay un poder impresionante en contar
historias
y que las historias hacen de nuestra
vida y le dije y dime tú qué otra cosa
sino contar una historia hacemos para
vender
contamos la historia de un producto y se
la contamos a alguien para que sea
alguien se crea esa historia de este
producto y entonces esa historia la haga
suya
y compra el producto
elige no tienes toda la razón no
deberías de contratarme a mí
no tengo esa experiencia pero sí sí sé
contar historias
él solamente me veía
todavía escuchaba es un vídeo de la luz
blanca
cerró su cuaderno
se levantó estrechó mi mano y me dijo
muchas gracias
nosotros vamos a estar en contacto
contigo
y se fue
fórmulas hay miles para contar historias
y cuando a mí me preguntan bueno y tú
qué haces para contar una historia yo
siempre les digo algo básico
mire
si tú me vas a contar una historia
primero piensa que esa historia tú la
vas a ver así como la vas a contar la
vas a ir a ver al cine y pregúntate tú
pagarías un boleto por ver la historia
que vas a contar
te quedarías al principio te saldrías a
la mitad de la película al final dirías
que al final me decepciona
ahí está la primera clave si tú pagarías
un boleto por ver esa historia
sabrías que esta historia tiene valor
porque el cine lo ha hecho durante toda
nuestra vida estamos acostumbrados a
consumir historias así
lo segundo es
que pienses tres cosas
qué le vas a contar a quién se lo vas a
contar y para qué se lo vas a contar si
respondes esas tres preguntas
y pagarías un boleto por quedarte a ver
esa película tienes una historia exitosa
tienes algo que contar
historias hay muchísimas está mi
historia tu historia
nuestra historia su historia la historia
de algo siempre hay una historia que
contar siempre
solamente hay que encontrarla las
historias tienen un valor infinito y el
saber contarlas cuando necesitamos
contarlas a quien necesitamos
contárselas eso
es el verdadero poder que hay ayer
detrás
pasaron las semanas
y los meses
un día recibí una llamada
era esa persona y me dijo beto
queremos que vengas a trabajar con
nosotros
así es una historia no la experiencia
una historia
me había conseguido una posición porque
no explotarla de ustedes
ahí está la tienen ustedes la conocen y
si no es la de ustedes es la de alguien
más o la ve algo más
realmente se habían puesto a pensar en
el valor que tienen esas historias
los griegos lo sabían
shakespeare lo sabía cuántas veces no
nos han contado romeo y julieta
georges lucas lo sabía
a los 36 billones de dólares de una
industria cinematográfica lo saben
las historias tienen un valor infinito
solamente hay que atrevernos a contarlas
tenemos que contar historias
[Aplausos]